office Christmas parties are coming up
folks office Christmas parties maybe
some of you are throwing them office
christmas parties are a lot of fun not
as much for sober people they're just
not many of you were sober I'm sober
things are less fun for us now on that
understand that stop living in a fantasy
world that things are as fun as they
used to be but things are not as fun as
they used to be but they're also not as
bad as they used to be there is the
trade-off and when you're an adult you
understand that that's what it is
life is a trade-off it is not as fun to
go to a Christmas party sober in fact
it's almost pointless not completely
pointless but it's almost pointless
because alcohol is that social lubricant
that allows you to really first of all
what alcohol allows you to do at
Christmas parties is you start looking
around at the people that you see every
day and you start appreciating them and
you start imagining that what's going on
constitutes a life which it doesn't at
all but alcohol allows you to believe
that sue from accounting in you or have
a bond because that one time she got
your name wrong but then she rushed a
change so that you could get paid by
Friday and remember that sue remember
that and remember when you came in the
kitchen and I was like eyeballing
Talia's lunch and you made that joke oh
don't steal the lunch and I didn't and
you know but you always kind of looked
at me skeptically sue because of that
and you thought maybe he was stealing
lunches and I wasn't what I was doing
this is a hypothetical what I was doing
is I was looking at what other people
ate that's what I was doing I wasn't
stealing anything but you need to why
don't you go back to your office and
[ __ ] get the names on the checks
right because I've worked here for seven
months sue so what alcohol allows you to
do is when you get really hammered you
don't want you to die in a car accident
anymore which is what you want every day
you want to say hello to sue you want to
say
how are you uh how's your daughter you
have a daughter oh she's and she's going
to Northwestern isn't that good sue
great yeah and then he do you make some
dumb joke and that's what it allows you
to do you look around at the people in
your orbit and you go oh these are
people and this is a life I'm living a
life this is a life this'll do this will
do it's Christmas I work at a shitty
company we all hate each other
world terrified of losing our job we're
working for this [ __ ] trunk loser
this whole thing's probably a Ponzi
scheme we're probably gonna be thrown
out into the street any minute but right
now there are lights on the bar there's
booze in my cup there's a Southwestern
eggroll if you're lucky enough to be a
Chili's if you're lucky enough to be at
Chili's there's a Southwestern egg roll
or there's a little shrimp with a tangy
[ __ ] you know cocktail sauce or you
know what are they love in Long Island
that bang bang shrimp that fried shrimp
with that chipotle aioli [ __ ] fires
cracker sauce where you know exactly
what I'm talking about and you can
nibble on that and booze it up while
bald Mike from accounting comes over and
tells a couple of street jokes that he
heard and if you have to do that sober
you want to shoot up the whole thing
it's hard to do it doesn't make any
sense because you realize very quickly
if you're sober that this is a horror of
all the places in my life I could have
ended up to end up in this shitty bar in
a strip mall with these losers in this
corner of the world is such a human
tragedy sure it's not as bad as stepping
on a landmine or having cancer or
getting [ __ ] every day by Senators and
that or having a [ __ ] you know an
adoption go wrong and then you're
getting burned with cigarettes I get it
people have worse problems but if you're
a sentient human being and you're
self-aware and you
look around and you have to [ __ ] have
another conversation with Denise Denise
who talks only about the one time she
went to Aruba and that she's saving up
for another cruise so she can take her
plump fat Italian ass and put it on the
top deck of a carnival ship so she can
tan and when I 10 I'm basically black
I'm basically black when I dan I did I'm
black I'm black when I dan and you have
to sit there and you have to listen to
these people these mouth-breathers they
don't have any idea that they two are
locked in this hell that they are in
this [ __ ] simulation but they are not
cursed with self-awareness like you are
they are like animals they don't have
the power of reason they don't think
they just fart and [ __ ] and move and the
pedal to the metal and then they stop
the car and start the car open the door
close the door take a [ __ ] I'm hungry
I'm not hungry
cocaine nostril boom that's what they do
but you for whatever reason have been
cursed like much of humanity with a
little self-awareness so when you're at
that bar and maybe you're a little early
and you're waiting in your car because
you don't want to be the first one there
but you're not gonna go home first cuz
if you go home first you know you're not
gonna [ __ ] go you know you're not
going if you go home first so you get to
the place a little [ __ ] early because
god forbid you work a little harder at
work so you get there a little early and
you're just in the bar and you get there
and you're alone and the only person
who's there is [ __ ] Ralph and Ralph
creepy as [ __ ] and he's probably a
pedophile you don't know but he's
[ __ ] weird because he talks about
high school girls a lot and that makes
you very uncomfortable and Ralph is
there and you're like [ __ ] I don't want
people walking in and seeing me and
Ralph's there but who walks in the boss
and he walks in because you're standing
there would [ __ ] Ralph and you're
like [ __ ] and the boss is there just to
make sure everything goes well tonight
you know because he knows he's running a
scam but at least he's got to keep
everyone invested in it once a year he
throws his stupid shitty Christmas party
we got a tray of wings a chafing dish of
you know balsamic chicken sub penne
vodka and you walk around you
commiserate with these [ __ ] dolts
that you work with and you have to see
every day and at that point some booze
and a few hits off a [ __ ] blunt or
vape can really go a long way a nice
cold cigarette when you're all lubed up
with some kettle one can really help a
holiday party just sail by it almost
might be fun it starts to get fun
because you start to realize it's not
that bad things aren't that bad things
aren't that bad look where other people
are that kid you grew up with he's dead
remember him no one he just disappeared
one day and they found him in a lake
what happened to him in those final
hours you'll never know but you're in
Long Island it's okay there's movie
theaters in Italian restaurants and
girls that might suck your dick if you
buy an eggplant parmesan things aren't
that bad and sure you didn't really do
anything with your life and you're just
floating around you're 25 years old
you're sexually weird and confused you
can barely perform with women you don't
have that many friends left many of them
have passed you by and they threaten you
so you get them out you know and it's
fine though because at the end of the
day these people at this shitty job see
promising you I mean do they really
let's be honest they hired you before
you even said anything they just needed
a warm body in their office to convince
themselves what they were doing was
[ __ ] reasonable but hey it doesn't
matter it's not not bad
because you can call that fat girl again
you bone last month maybe she'll be
involved and then you can just [ __ ] not
even cuz you enjoy it just cuz you can
say to yourself well I'm [ __ ] I'm
part of it things gonna happen you can
imagine that shitty little Levitt home
you'll buy in a few years when you just
save your money and your parents are
proud of you because you finally have a
basement apartment in Hicksville with
Formica counters okay so things aren't
that bad you're not in jail you're not
in prison you're not dead you know it's
it's a [ __ ] it's what you do you
measure yourself against the absolute
lowest of the low you say to yourself
hey I'm not shooting up schools look at
me I'm not doing anything wrong I
just here and maybe it's a dead-end job
and maybe I have nothing left I have
nothing in common with these people and
every passion that I have
I've extinguished because they've all
frightened me but it doesn't matter
because I had a few kettle ones and I
smoked a joint
Ralph's kind of funny now and Denise
she's a big goofball she's saving for a
cruise you know when she can she looks
black she's got a big fat ass
and you might [ __ ] that ass who knows
it's weird but then there's another guy
in the office Clark he's kind of gender
nonspecific would you let call Clark
blow you in a bathroom you don't know
that's for the third of the fourth drink
to town and you actually start liking
your boss even though he's clearly a
criminal and he'll probably be in jail
in a few years what he says make sense
about hustling and grinding and just
making it happen he didn't need a
college degree you know he didn't need
you know any discernible talent or skill
he just kept pushing through kept
calling old people and telling them they
should remortgage their house okay and
you just followed that because you
wanted to prove that you're a real man
with Alexis and in those situations it
is so essential so essential to have a
cocktail a stuffed mushroom